l'antonov 225 le plus gros avion du
monde a fait une rare apparition
au-dessus l'aéroport commercial de
grabels la dernière remontait à 2012
en ces temps de confinement les
distractions sont rares et l'occasion
d'apercevoir ne serait ce que quelques
instants ce mastodonte du ciel a attiré
pas mal de gens oublient eu parfois des
consignes construit en ukraine à la fin
de l'ère soviétique
l'antonov 225 baptisé bria le rêve n'a
pu être construit qu'un seul exemplaire
[Applaudissements]
six réacteurs est un train
d'atterrissage de 28 roues pour
transporter à l'origine de 150 tonnes de
chars d'assaut et des machines de guerre
depuis la mi-avril se consacre au
transport de matériel de protection
médicale en l'occurrence 940 mètres
cubes
des centaines de milliers de blouses de
protection pour le gouvernement du
québec
la cargaison a été chargée à l'aéroport
de tianjin au sud de pékin
l'antonov fait escale à anchorage en
alaska
avant de rejoindre mirabel l'opération
s'est réalisée dans un secret relatif de
peur d'un échec annoncé alexandre la
compagnie très dense lui partenaire de
ses parts gagnant du groupe bears alger
ainsi il a fallu attendre l'atterrissage
pour connaître l'identité du client
l'importateur de mois d'efforts pour ce
résultat
en partenariat avec la cdp réussi
énormément
à avoir les bons contacts en chine pour
nous faciliter on a trouvé du matériel
on l'a proposé au gouvernement et ils
ont donné leur aval pour pouvoir être
capable de faire entrer ce monsieur
lépine c'est jean françois lépine
représentants du québec en chine qui
n'en est pas à sa première importation
de matériel
un véritable casse tête c'est complexe
parce que d'abord les manufactures sont
répartis partout en chine il ya des
enjeux de transport routier il ya
plusieurs compagnies chinoises qui
fournissent le matériel dans cet avion
là donc il faut coordonner tout ça
arrive et des jours à l'avance pour être
sûr d'arriver à la douane atteint au
départ c'est l' agence gouvernementale
sigma santé qui reçoit les appels
d'offres pour le matériel recherché
ensuite l'importateur contacter un
transporteur en l'occurrence nos lits
nord nos leaders ne possède pas d'avions
capables d'aller jusqu'en chine
normalement c'est une firme de toronto
qui s'appelle momentum solution qui nous
appellent pour analyser nos avions et
cette fois c'est nous qui les avons
contactés pour autres écouteurs vous
êtes un courtier en transe parce que
vous n'y trouvez un avion d'importance
pour les chercher deux cargos en chine
la solution c'est le gros entonnant avec
lequel momentum solution a déjà réalisé
des opérations humanitaires
[Applaudissements]
la veille à hamilton un boeing 767 de la
compagnie cargo jet atterri avec une
grosse cargaison de masques n95
provenance shanghai avec deux escales ce
type d'avion en a besoin
une à tokyo l'autre à vancouver avant de
gagner hamilton siège principal de
cargos jet
les masques sont pour le gouvernement
fédéral qui les distribuera aux
provinces raison de plus pour le fédéral
air canada et cargo jets ont effectué 20
voyages dernièrement un par jour la
semaine dernière car le canada mal
préparés à manque encore cruellement de
matériel de protection
ainsi le ministère a commandé plus de
327 millions de masques chirurgicaux et
n'en a reçu que 26 millions pour les n95
154 millions ont été commandés seulement
9 millions ont été reçus l'avantagent
des boeing deux cargos jet c'est qu'ils
se chargent rapidement à l'aéroport de
shanghai
car ils ne peuvent pas rester longtemps
au sol ou le courtier en transport
bolloré logistics s'occupe de
l'entreposage et des douanes
tout est extrêmement complexe disons qu
actuellement la production en chine est
un rythme intéressant donc il ya moins
de cannibalisme entre les pays entre les
c'est plus contrôlé le problème c'est
encore le volume dans les aéroports
parce qu'il ya principalement l'aéroport
de shanghai qui est le principal
aéroport de départ des produits médicaux
alors imaginez la congestion dans les
douanes dans les entrepôts des aéroports
alors c'est un défi logistique très
important
il a fallu huit heures pour charger
l'antonov 225 à tianjin
il en faudra presque autant pour
décharger à mirabel parce que l'énorme
appareil n'est pas adapté à ce genre de
transport à ces voyages vont durer
encore des mois on commence à envisager
l'option maritime pour les besoins en
moyen et long terme tant que la
production canadienne de matériel de
protection n'est pas prêt à prendre le
relais
je le ferai